monsieur le ministre je ne me lève pas
pour vous saluer
bonjour c'est la dernière provocation de
la jeunesse iranienne depuis quelques
jours elle s'attaque directement au
symbole du pouvoir en faisant tomber
dans geste désinvoltes les turbans des
je suis en train de vous expliquer mais
vous n'écoutez pas la fin de mon
intervention que nous sommes en train de
changer en France en France cette
situation de l'autre côté monsieur
dussobe lui le ministre du Travail qui
nous annonce très clairement des
régularisations en grand nombre de
travailleurs clandestins voir un nouvel
appel d'air ce que nous proposons c'est
de mettre fin à une forme d'hypocrisie
et vos cas par cas de permettre à ces
hommes et à ses femmes qui sont sur le
territoire qui travaillent et qui
occupent ces postes dans des secteurs en
tension de demander leur régularisation
et d'obtenir un titre de séjour dans ce
cadre c'est comme au patinage artistique
c'est les figures obligées de la vie
politique tout le monde répète la même
chose bon avec une situation qui quel
que soit ce qu'on en pense de toute
manière l'immigration n'est pas
responsable du chômage l'immigration
n'est pas responsable de l'insécurité il
s'agit d'envisager la régularisation
d'un certain nombre de clandestins qui
sont utilisés par des patrons qui
eux-mêmes devraient se retrouver
d'ailleurs devant le tribunal
correctionnel pour employer des gens qui
sont sans-papiers je crois que les
ministres ont abordés la question de
quelques milliers c'est le cas
aujourd'hui en tout cas avec la
circulaire valse on parle de 7 à 8000
il y a pas de plan cachés de naturalisme
ou de régularisation massives
d'humain et d'efficaces ce projet de loi
sera débattu au premier semestre 2023
rappelons que les métiers en tension qui
ont le plus recours à l'emploi immigré
sont ceux de la maison comme du ménage
ou de l'aide à domicile le gardiennage
et la sécurité le BTP et l'hôtellerie on
sait que l'utilisation de l'immigration
pèse à la baisse sur les salaires sauf
que ce sont des métiers que les Français
ne veulent pas faire mais ça fait 40 ans
que j'entends ça aussi
vous savez parce que nous combattons la
Punité nous renforçons les moyens de la
justice vous voyez ça fait trois ans que
ce Parlement vote une augmentation sans
précédentes des crédits de la justice
encore 8% cette année et vous savez quoi
vous avez voté contre tous vous avez
voté contre l'augmentation des moyens de
la justice malgré des chiffres
incontestables vous continuez votre
auto-satisfaction et vous tentez de
faire diversion mais le problème c'est
qu'en continuant à faire la politique de
l'autruche parce que vous êtes
incroyablement aveuglé par votre
idéologie vous ne réglerez jamais les
problèmes des Français les prévisions
météo indiquent une détérioration
significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est violence
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à le dire le racisme n'a pas sa
place dans notre démocratie le bureau de
l'assemblée se réunira et naturellement
je devrais prendre les sanctions qui
sont
suspension de séance de 5 minutes un
record du monde celui du plus long vol
au-dessus d'un relief en wingsuit il a
été réalisé la semaine dernière par les
soulflyers le célèbre trio français
vient nous envoyer ces images
de peau je suis né en France je suis
député français et je pensais pas
aujourd'hui qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
j'allais me faire insulter est-ce que
c'est pas toute la stratégie de
respectabilité du parti qui est en train
de sauter là
du bateau de migrants très clairement il
parlait du bateau j'ai dit quand le
député de la France insoumise parler du
bateau SOS Méditerrané qui ne parvenait
pas à accoster sur les côtes européennes
j'y répondu qu'il retourne en Afrique
est-ce que la phrase qu'il retourne en
Afrique peut avoir sa place dans la
semaine nationale mais ce qui peut avoir
sa place dans la France c'est le
programme du rassemble national les
clandestins les migrants qui sont amenés
par ces bateaux doivent retourner à la
porte d'attache qui est en Afrique ce
que je regrette c'est la manipulation de
la France insoumise qui cherche en toute
circonstances à faire des incidents de
débat en dénaturant les propos de ses
adversaires pour ne pas parler du fond
en fait un exploit de trois minutes et 5
secondes sur plus de 7 km avant
l'ouverture du parachute